[Musica]
sin da piccoli Ci sentiamo dire devi
portare rispetto
devi avere rispetto non mancare di
rispetto Ma cos'è il rispetto
il rispetto nel corso della storia ha
avuto una serie di definizioni nella
filosofia Siamo passati dal rispetto
inteso come
deferenza verso l'autorità Quindi
pensiamo all'imperatore nel passato ai
Papi oggi al Presidente della Repubblica
al preside della scuola
poi la filosofia la storia ci hanno
accompagnato e l'hanno fatta crescere ed
evolvere come una definizione Intesa di
apprezzamento
il radrezzamento verso l'eccezionalità
quindi un talento pensiamo a uno
sportivo che compiono impresa
straordinaria pensiamo al primo uomo
sulla Luna quindi ma non era sufficiente
oggi siamo in un contesto in cui il tema
della diversità dell'inclusione del
rispetto sono preponderanti e quindi
oggi siamo arrivati a definire il
rispetto come riconoscimento cioè valore
della persona in quanto tale in quanto
autonoma in quanto unica e irripetibile
a prescindere dall'età dal sesso
dall'etnia dall'orientamento sessuale
dalla disabilità quindi il
riconoscimento oggi è
riconoscere l'altro per quello che è
e la sua possibilità di affermazione e
di realizzazione individuale
Ma come possiamo essere più rispettosi
se vogliamo davvero riconoscere il
valore dell'altro per quello che è per
quello che può portare ogni giorno nelle
realtà in cui lavoriamo nella scuola
nelle nostre aziende
lo possiamo fare agendo dei
comportamenti Innanzitutto non
comportando avanti quel rispetto che
possiamo definire passivo Cioè non fare
non prevaricare non mancare di rispetto
Appunto magari non mettendo i piedi sul
tavolo magari non sbattendo le porte
quando siamo arrivati con la mamma e il
papà o col fratello e la sorella magari
non rispondendo male al compagno al
collega ma non è sufficiente perché per
essere rispettosi bisogna farlo in
maniera attiva bisogna impegnarsi
bisogna prendersi la responsabilità di
esserlo e lo possiamo fare con dei
comportamenti che possono essere guidati
dalla capacità di ascoltare ascoltare
dedico tempo e attenzione per
riconoscere le tue idee e accettarle con
obiettività senza pregiudizi senza
stereotipi perché il tuo punto di vista
arricchisce il mio più ci ascoltiamo e
più siamo capaci di crescere Pensiamo ad
esempio quando siamo a tavola no capita
tutti i giorni Magari stiamo parlando
tra amici tra
genitori figli io con le mie colleghe e
i miei colleghi e magari siamo impegnati
a fare altro guardiamo il telefonino
Magari rispondiamo una mail Ecco invece
prenderci il tempo per ascoltare l'altro
davvero guardarlo negli occhi Attenzione
anche al modo in cui parliamo quello è
voler essere rispettosi
possiamo essere più rispettosi se siamo
più empatici cioè facciamo nostri i
bisogni dell'altro quindi riconosciamo e
Comprendiamo i bisogni e gli stati
d'animo molto spesso diciamo mi metto
nei tuoi panni oppure Prova a metterti
nei miei panni ma cosa vuol dire davvero
Questo vuol dire capire quali sono le
emozioni che gli altri provano in un
determinato momento io la mattina quando
entro in ufficio dico Buongiorno saluto
le persone che lavorano con me e cerco
di guardare nei loro occhi Se quella è
una mattina che inizia col sorriso
oppure no e se mi rendo conto che magari
è un momento un po' particolare
metto giù il computer metto giù il
cappotto e dico andiamo a prenderci un
caffè il chiedere come stai Il chiedere
come posso aiutarti o magari quando si
sta svolgendo un compito un progetto
vuol dire guardare se l'altra persona
magari è in difficoltà e quindi
comprendere come noi possiamo aiutarlo
Questo vuol dire essere più rispettosi
possiamo essere più rispettosi se
pensiamo alla reciprocità la reciprocità
vuol dire adottare un comportamento che
faccia sentire l'altro esattamente come
io vorrei che mi sentissi per il suo
comportamento quindi nella nostra
diversità Noi siamo pari il concetto di
reciprocità è qualcosa che acquisisce
ancora più valore perché nelle
definizioni di rispetto di cui vi ho
parlato in avvio cioè la deferenza Per
l'autorità o l'apprezzamento per il
talento erano di pochi no Quindi non era
un concetto di superiorità che va oltre
riconoscere la persona per quello che è
e nella nostra diversità Noi siamo pari
quindi dare a tutti le pari opportunità
la mia nonna che è nata nel 1910 una
persona molto semplice Molto unimi ha
sempre detto lì c'è Ricordati che puoi
imparare anche dall'ultimo persona che
incontri per strada perché tutti hanno
una storia da raccontare e tutti noi
abbiamo qualcosa da imparare dagli altri
un altro modo per essere più rispettosi
è valorizzare quindi creare Quel
contesto in cui le persone si possono
sentire riconosciute e apprezzate
come farlo farlo vuol dire creare un
team come quello che ho fatto io in cui
la diversità non potrebbe essere più
diversa perché veniamo da regioni
diverse abbiamo età diverse abbiamo
religioni diverse qualcuna è anche una
disabilità importante e quindi creare
quel momento ad esempio nelle riunioni
in cui tutti possono contribuire a dire
la loro quindi essere davvero partecipi
essere davvero coinvolti di quello di
cui stiamo parlando in quel momento del
progetto che stiamo avviando valorizzare
vuol dire saper dire anche Grazie vuol
dire celebrare i nostri successi grazie
a una parola meravigliosa fa bene a chi
la dice e fa bene a chi la riceve e se
lo facciamo con un sorriso Magari oggi
che possiamo farlo anche con un
abbraccio perché ci è permesso è
veramente dirompente e celebrare i
nostri successi Quindi anche piccoli
Perché dietro all'impegno anche se il
lavoro non è fatto benissimo Magari
avremmo potuto fare meglio ma
sicuramente ci sono tante persone che si
sono impegnate hanno studiato ci hanno
provato Magari hanno sbagliato però
saper dire grazie sicuramente aumenta la
loro autostima e aumenta la fiducia ma
soprattutto la voglia di stare insieme
l'ultimo comportamento che potrebbe
essere quello di guidarti di essere
guidati dalla Cooperazione la
cooperazione vuol dire lavorare insieme
per un obiettivo comune vuol dire
mettere insieme le competenze che
abbiamo le canosse capacità le nostre
storie metterle a fattor comune perché
questo davvero ci permette di
raggiungere un obiettivo insieme
Pensiamo ad esempio ad una staffetta di
atletica no Quindi 4% di atletica ci
sono i 100 metri Ognuno ha i suoi 100
metri da compiere ma lo fa con il suo
stile lo fa con il suo passo magari
anche con il suo tempo e non è tanto il
tempo che poi sarà diciamo la somma
complessiva dei quattro pezzi ma come Le
differenti atleti sapranno ascoltarsi a
sentire i passi dell'altro magari
guardare un attimino sapersi fermare per
capire quando è il momento giusto per
prendere il testimone perché quello è il
momento in cui davvero si sta andando
verso un'unica direzione Io non sono un
appassionato di motociclismo però mi ha
colpito L'altro giorno ho sentito
Bagnaia credo il nome del campione del
MotoGP del 2022 che ha vinto con la
Ducati mi ha colpito molto il fatto che
lui abbia detto che loro si sono
ascoltati hanno cooperato si sono
sentiti reciprocamente di aiuto perché
lui ha dato le istruzioni ai meccanici i
meccanici hanno ascoltato lui perché
andava sulla moto e quindi hanno fatto
veramente gioco di squadra Questo vuol
dire cooperare
se pensiamo quindi che oggi la diversità
è un valore è un valore Perché ognuno
nella sua peculiarità nella sua unicità
è un pezzo della vita di tutti Ecco la
diversità Oggi deve essere quel valore
che ci permette di lavorare
sull'inclusione se l'inclusione della
diversità può essere paragonato a
organizzare una festa Io adoro ballare
che mi conosce in sala lo sa e se la
diversità è essere invitati a una festa
l'inclusione essere invitati a ballare a
me è capitato tante volte quando ero
vivo la vostra età di andare a una festa
e magari Timidamente perché non
conoscevo bene i passi non ballavo e mi
mettevo in un angolo Ecco l'inclusione
oggi vuol dire saper prendere quel
compagno quell'amico che non si sente di
ballare e farlo entrare sulla pista a
prescindere che sappiano ballare
Questo vuol dire creare un valore per il
futuro vuol dire creare un valore per la
nostra società quindi se pensiamo allo
sguardo avanti al futuro lavorare sulla
diversità e sull'inclusione un tema di
cui oggi mi occupo nelle aziende vuol
dire creare un futuro migliore creare un
futuro Per chi verrà dopo di noi Io non
ho figli non ho avuto figli però mi sono
sempre chiesta cosa potevo fare io per
lasciare qualcosa di me domani ed è
quello di prendermi cura delle persone
per cui lavorare oggi sui temi
dell'inclusione della diversità è
qualcosa che mi riempie di orgoglio
il futuro se lo creiamo insieme ognuno
di noi fa un pezzetto in più per essere
rispettoso verso l'altro per accoglierlo
accettarlo per quello che è e non per
quello che noi vorremmo che fosse per
ciò che può portare ogni giorno nel
contesto in cui lavoriamo saremo davvero
capaci di creare un futuro sostenibile
Questo vuol dire quindi lasciare un
eredità vuol dire lasciare come mi piace
citare sempre in alcuni momenti di
formazione la storia degli All Blacks
gli All Blacks sono la squadra di rugby
neozelandese che ha vinto di più in
assoluto nella storia ecco i giocatori
segnalo degli All Blacks hanno una
regola molto ferrea devono pulire lo
spogliatoio quando è finita la partita
devono piegare le maglie di tutta la
squadra e metterle in un posto migliore
il senso È che noi che stiamo oggi
costruendo un futuro per voi dobbiamo
lavorare per lasciare la nostra maglia
in un posto migliore e farlo bisogna
farlo comportandosi dando l'esempio
seguire gli esempi e non i consigli mia
mamma mi dice sempre i consigli sono
come l'olio di ricino facciamo fatica a
mandarli giù Ma ad esempio no tutti noi
ci guardiamo noi seguiamo Gli esempi dei
nostri nonni prima poi dei nostri
genitori dei nostri insegnanti dei
nostri responsabili io sono una
responsabile e quindi sicuramente
l'impegno che mi prende ogni giorno è
quello di dare l'esempio dare l'esempio
perché
un grammo di comportamento vale più di
un chilo di parole quindi siamo tutti un
pochino più rispettosi da domani per il
vostro futuro grazie
[Applauso]